hey what's going on it's Bill bur and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
and I'm just checking in on
you
Ola
Bon
Miss
um um I'm back into my French and I
[__] love dude I have been listening
to French on the [__] radio and I'm
start I'm telling you I always think
like people always I just learn how to
speak English and they would just you
know people that move here also known as
immigrants also known as the enemy of
the Republican
party you don't need any more [__]
people right and then Liberals are all
like I like new people unless they live
here next to me we should let everybody
in as long as I don't have to look at
them Liberals are really weird with that
you know Republicans are just kind of
like you
know Republicans look at the United
States like you know when you're going
to a concert and you pull up to that
that parking lot to park they just have
that sign
full that's how they
view immigrants and then like liberals I
feel like that's [__] there's a
parking spot
there you
know as long as it's far away from my
[__] loft or whatever the hell their
deal is I don't know what is I just
don't have any faith in [__] humanity
and just the awful things that we're
doing to one
another um at the top level you know
when you really look at like the worst
things that human beings do it's usually
on a collective level in the ver in the
in the in the um some sort of invasion
or some sort of war and it's always
manifested by uh these [__] psychos
everybody else is just kind of [__]
cool you know you got your occasional
serious killer you got your occasional
woman who just makes some [__] up about
a uh someone on the Dodgers pitching
staff and then they find the [__]
text messages that sort of shed a whole
new light on it but nobody pays
attention because she has a [__]
vagina and then meanwhile that guy
didn't even get a chance to [__]
defend
himself you know you have that [__]
going on but that's few and far
between you know what I
mean it's really I don't I don't
understand like
leaders leaders of the world it's a
bigger thing it's why I don't watch the
[__] news it's why I stay away from
it and when I spot people that I know
are air quote informed I really think
this CIA is the first person that that
looks at the news and then they they
give you know they give you know they
censor it and then give it to CNN and
fox and then they spin it their way so
it's sort of double spun and then people
people watch it and then think that they
know what's going on and they
don't I don't know why that's so [__]
you know what my [__]
dream would be if everybody just one day
on the same [__] day just stopped
watching CNN and Fox News and they were
just like what the [__] and nobody said
anything and there wasn't any chatter
about it on Reddit that we were going to
do it there was no chatter about it on
social media just everybody just stopped
watching those stupid [__] channels
everybody on those channels and those
networks should be tried for treason all
they their job every day is to divide
America and make us all yell at each
other but just imagine if everybody just
stopped watching it and it just all went
[__]
bankrupt right and then everybody just
stopped paying attention to the news
like how freaked out the handful of
psychos that run everything like how
will we maintain control if they're not
reading our Liv
lies those are the things that I think
about when I'm in a
diner right I think about that when I go
into a diner I think about how I should
get the side salad but I'm actually
going to get the fries extra crispy and
then I also wonder why how a a
store-bought pie be it a slice or the
whole thing never [__] tastes good
but if you make one at home they're
unbelievable there's just something you
cannot buy a store-bought
pie at a diner anywhere I've never been
to a place ever in my life that has good
pie it makes no sense unless it's like
one of those European ones one of those
meat
pies shepherds pie or some [__] like
that those taste F fantastic if you go
to the right place but nowhere in these
United States of America have I ever
gone out you know because I remember I
used to see that there was uh what was
it true
romance
they were talking about you go see a
movie was that the movie you go see the
movie and then you afterwards you go to
a diner and you get a slice of pie and
you talk about it and I remember that
was old Billy [__] uh Billy round
ball you know let's throw the rock
around I was all about sports I I wasn't
into the [__]
asss you know I didn't know how to write
scripts I didn't know any of that [__] I
didn't give a [__] about Cinema I mean I
liked it but I was like more like you
know I just went to these these action
[__] movies like me for like but my
idea of a [__] movie was one guy
walks into a bar by himself and
everybody tries to beat the [__] out of
him and then he beats the [__] out of
all of them like those were the movies
that I watched I wasn't into uh like
I'll be honest with you all right I
watched Citizen Kane I didn't get
it I but my [__] brain was so add
like I got bored halfway through it um I
have to go back and watch it now um
because evidently it's supposed to be a
really good
movie that used to happen to me a lot
like I had massive massive [__] add
and I think a lot of it had to do with
like how I was born and then also the
[__] that happened to me and my brain
was just [__] I was like trying to
get a squirrel to pay attention I
remember I Saw The Usual Suspects and
somewhere in that movie I daydreamed and
in the end when they found out he was
lying and the whole crowd was going like
oh god oh and he straightened his foot
out and [__] I was just like
wow this must have been really cool if
you were paying
attention you know what's funny I told
Kevin Pollock that one time I was doing
this podcast and before he even finished
the story he started [__] dying
laughing because he thought it was
hilarious because that's the whole thing
of that movie and then I think over the
years through doing going to therapy and
yoga and mushrooms and [__] like I could
start
watching like movies like the six sense
and you know basically if you didn't
tell me what the [__] movie was and
what was going to happen in the first8
minutes and I don't mean setting it up
like if I couldn't guess where it was
going to go you know then
uh I mean whatever whatever big surprise
turn you had in the end
I I I I it was lost on me
um so I think that's a victory now for
me that my brain is calmed down and I
can actually enjoy [__] movies but
anyways they talked about going out and
getting a slice of pie and talking about
the movie and I'm like that sounds
amazing I'd like to go to a movie with
the beautiful struggling actress and
then we go out and get us some pie no
pun intended you know maybe get a second
slice laptop everybody yeah [__]
[__]
um and I quickly found out going out
like first of all most people don't even
make a pie they just make those stupid
custards so they have some store-bought
horeshit and then they just put like
this sugary like almost tastes like air
like just a bunch of Cool Whip and then
they put some chocolate shavings on top
and then they're going to sit there and
be like that's a Boston cream pie it's
like that isn't that's a store-bought
pie with a whole bunch of [__]
whipped
cream
um is what that is and it's uh this
doesn't taste like anything this tastes
like you didn't give a [__] when you
made this you slap this thing together
like it's been here for a while
you know you know who orders pie too
[__] old
people you know and I think most of them
are dead now when I was growing up old
people loved pie and I'm also finding
that a lot of people don't like cake
which really blows my
mind you know because this every day
there's somebody's birthday and there's
you know somebody getting a birthday
cake and there's like a really good
chance that they don't even like
it happy birthday dear Phil
up oh Jesus why' they get me a cake
happy birthday to you I mean they really
even my friends if they don't know that
about me how old are you
now
um you know there's a lot of hate going
around too about the [__] red velvet
cake which I think is really sort of
Ginger adjacent it's funny like no one
has a problem with like the chocolate
cake you know the cake of color nobody
has a problem with uh what's another
kind of cake the German chocolate or
anything like that the one that gets all
the [__]
hate is the uh it's the red velvet
one what's so matter you guys can't
handle a tender
Ginger um I am literally not talking
about anything this is a very confusing
time of year for me I'm trying to watch
NFL Football October baseball and my
Boston Bruins start
tonight against the Chicago Blackhawks
and and the latest [__] you know
Superstar that's named Connor and I
guess he went out for pregame warm-ups
without his helmet
on which was really sort of a musical
theater thing to do I felt I guess him I
guess he and somebody else got [__]
fine 2500 bucks for not having their
helmet on you know but I get it he's 19
years old he's in Chicago there's a
bunch of hotties in the crowd you know
he wants them to see look at me look at
me all young and good-look making a
bunch of money who wants to ride it who
wants to ride my [__] stick after the
game I that's what he was
doing that's what I think trying to
cause controversy so anyway we we're
playing them tonight and I got Thursday
Night Football I got to watch inside the
NFL I got October baseball I'm so
[__] the team that I was going to
watch the
uh the Baltimore Orioles they got swag
I was talking to Josh adamaya about it
he's a Baltimore guy he was right he's
like H you know they're young 101
[__] wins right down the goddamn
tubes I know what that feels like last
season with the Bruins we had 101 wins
we had 101 wins last year in an 82 game
series season I mean figure that one out
no we had a bunch you know and then we
[__] lost to the
Panthers goddamn seven G game
series I still maintain that kachuck kid
should have been the [__] finals MVP
Stanley Cup Final MVP or whatever
whatever the playoff MVP there's no
[__] way that team should have gone
that far that guy how many times did he
scor the tying or go-ahead
goal you know guy did it with a [__]
cracked
sternum his brother had to come in and
help him get dressed for Christ's sake
and he still goes out and scores a
[__] goal
and then you got me out there at pickup
hockey I take one I take a wrist shot
off my [__] toe and I'm done for the
night skates are coming
off I'm getting back into a hybrid
vehicle I have my I have my my foot
elevated up on the dashboard you know
you know [__] drive down the street
you ever seen them you ever see a [__]
driving down the street one foot on the
gas and the other one's like [__]
hanging out the window it's like it's
just this NeverEnding cycle of getting
[__] and giving birth so they just
like that's their muscle memory of how
when they sit
down
sorry um anyway so I've been back on the
uh off of the road here and I got a I
got a benefit tomorrow night for or
tonight when this thing comes out for
the people out there in Hawaii and all
that horrible [__] that happened to them
and like look at all that
stuff how it look like a controlled burn
like something
I I want to believe that conspiracy
theory but I'm just like why not just
eminent domain the whole thing that's
what they usually do like oh we got to
put a Trader Joe's here then they just
kick you out and then you're like the
the supermarket's never built then a big
glass Mansion goes up and you're like
hey wait a
minute can I speak to the senator we're
sorry he's not in right now can we take
a
message
um so yeah meta meds put put something
together so he asked me to do it so all
accolades go to him he's the one who put
it together so I'll be doing that but
other than that I just been hanging out
with my
kids uh I made some pumpkin bread cuz
it's that time of year instead of doing
popcorn in a movie this time of year we
do pumpkin bread in a movie which is
fantastic no pie even though I can make
you know something I swear to God if I
ever had to get out of this
business okay old Billy Pie Face would
immediate medely
open I'd make a couple of [__] pies
that would be it I'd have a little
[__] van like this is how much my
life would shrink you know everyone in
my life would leave me all right
everybody leaves me and then I'm just
out there by myself and I got this van
and I got to pick up the
pieces you know and I don't know which
way to go and I just I know what give
the masses what they want they want a
store bought pie that tastes like it was
made at home you tell me one [__]
place that does it
all right first of all you got the worst
of the worst like
McDonald's whatever the [__] they had it
was like they were trying to end the
Pi's existence you know like how Clear
Channel destroyed radio like McDonald's
with apple pie they made the Clear
Channel version of apple
pie I mean how do you make a
flavorless apple pie and by the way do
you ever wonder what what is in that
[__] [__] goo that filling they got
the apples but like the the the other
stuff that's in there that's supposed to
be like sugar and lemon juice and uh
what else do you [__] I can't even
remember I haven't made one in so
long what the [__] else did I used to
put in I it's a really you know it's a
small little concoction and that's what
you bathe all the apple slices in I
don't know what theirs is but you know
you know what it is you know it's that
pink slime that they putting their
burgers they just put sugar in it and
they just injected into that
[__] it's terrible you know what
kills me is I would always get it hoping
to get a good one and they never tasted
good and I would still [__] get one
when I was a kid and then finally I was
just like this tastes like [__] and it's
burning my [__] mouth and I finally
stopped doing it and I can't even tell
you the last time I had one like the
last time I had one it looked like a
burit
that you deep fried like a little one um
it was like shaped like a [__]
Blackboard eraser that was the last time
I had one of their apple pies I don't
know I kind of lost touch with
McDonald's a long time ago when all of a
sudden they got out of their wheelhouse
when they just started to like when they
had like a salad bar it's like just
don't do that you know what that
reminded me of is like some of the metal
bands that got in right at the end of
the [__] heavy metal scene and then
grunge took over over and they were
totally like leathered out with
eyeliner in like when their 90 1991
album came out and then when they did
their followup in
1993 they were wearing flannels and
trying to do the [__] grunge thing
you
know it's like the [__] are you
doing I feel like that's what uh I don't
even know what my [__] point was
somehow that made me think of
that the switch that they did on the
[__] apple pie that's not going to be
a triangle it's going to be shaped like
a [__] log it's going to look like
what your body wants to do just [__]
this thing out I'll tell you the only
band I ever saw that did sort of the
glam metal thing and then sort of went
into grunge and then found their own way
I don't know they found their own way I
don't think it was grunch but it was
panta panta early
on early
on you know was doing like the [__]
Glam thing and I'm so glad that they
didn't because uh Vinnie Paul one of my
favorite drummers ever just one of just
the one of the tightest bands ever and
that guy had the sickest [__]
Groove um and he's also a [__] great
guy he was an also great guy I met him a
couple times he would come out to the
comedy clubs um but like you don't want
to see that guy in
makeup you know what I
mean it just was not a good [__] look
you know he looks in makeup he looked
when he was in his 20s he looks he
looked like what kiss looks like now in
makeup you know and they're little older
and a little fatter I guess I got to do
some reads here um but anyway Vinnie
Paul man [__] amazing goddamn drummer
I guess they're back out what's left of
panta which is Rex Brown and Phil are
out there I got to go see them
um I should have seen him back in the
day I never did I gotta be honest with
you dude I'm just too [__] old you
know and I said watch these [__]
goddamn
uh
like like cell phone footage of sporting
events now and I'm watching teams
scoring touchdowns and then grown men
like pelvic
pumping right in front of some guy's
face that's for like the other team like
I think I'm just old now cuz some of my
buddies are going like dude I would
never go to sporting vent these fans are
[__] animals now and it's like I I
actually think they're not as bad
because there is cell phone cameras
everywhere there's only so much Behavior
I mean there's always going to be fights
but like I think our Behavior was way we
were way way way more over served when I
was a kid and I just think that
uh at least I was I remember that I just
think like when you just you just get
[__] old you know what it is you get
old and if you have a house and you have
a nice TV you're just like why why the
[__] would I
go
if you're a man of a particular age and
you have a nice flat screen [__]
TV you know and you can hit pause and go
out and smoke a cigar and come back and
I don't have to listen to people [__]
screaming and yelling and getting into
fights and then that's another [__]
first down screaming in my [__] that's
another thing it's just too [__] loud
like uh I actually think a lot of rock
concerts now are
quieter than like an NFL game or like um
a Vegas kns game I'm just too [__]
old to go to that [__] or that Lakers
game I went to earlier this year where
the DJ literally played the whole
[__]
game um yeah I really am I'm Billy old
man you know that sphere thing I have no
[__]
desire to go see that and stand there
with a bunch of people with their cell
phones out the whole [__] show have
you seen the videos of those things
everybody has their [__] thing out
nobody is filming the band and then
everybody's just looking at the ceiling
going oh my god dude oh my go what the
[__] like the whole
time and Bono's down there trying to
save the world and no one's listening to
him um see the something [__]
something it's never the biggest YouTube
fan radio
more and I
wait I actually you know I always kind
of like you too but then he had this bit
he was doing where he was bringing guys
girlfriends out of the crowd and he was
like singing to them and spooning with
them and right there just as a man you
should be allowed to go on stage and
beat the [__] out of him and it's
security be like all right listen you
know we're here for psychos what you're
doing with this man's girlfriend in
front of him and everybody else like you
you should be getting this this is a
natural response this person is not a
psycho you know I was on Instagram and
somebody was saying that this guy came
out and he said to the crowd tonight you
guys are all my girlfriends and the
women all go nuts and you stand there as
like a guy like dude what the [__] don't
do that passive aggressive [__] [__] you
and your [__]
music I'll tell you it was a wild one do
you remember a long time a long time ago
one of those pop stars I don't want to
say the wrong person but would literally
bring a guy out of the crowd and do a
[__] lap
dance with the
dude and this woman was smoking hot and
I cannot imagine if you were there with
your wife or your
girlfriend she's up there [__]
putting her iconic clam on your junk you
know and you're just sitting there like
dude I work at Home Depot I never
thought that my dick was going to be a
around one of these Mount Rushmore
vaginas you know what sucks is
afterwards if you were there with your
girlfriend you'd have to act like you
were
embarrassed like you didn't enjoy it I
bet you [__] loved that didn't you of
course I did it was [__]
amazing I would have [__] her in front
of you I mean what are we doing here you
know Lenny Kravitz brought you up on
stage and started dry humping you and
you started telling me that you didn't
enjoy it like I'm going to I'm like I'm
going to [__] believe
that [__] dreadlock [__] was all over
[Laughter]
you you know it's you know you it takes
a certain level of good-looking to pull
off leatherpants and you're almost
60 Lenny Kravitz still doing it you know
there's only two guys I ever saw over
the age of SE of 50 that could still
pull off leather pants Lenny Kravitz and
Rob Alfred all
right
everyone that's that's that that's for
everyone there's something for everyone
in those two people um I actually a
buddy of mine went to go see Judith
Priest the other night and uh he sent me
some video and Rob hordred sounds as
great as he he ever has Guy's [__] 72
years old sounds absolutely amazing and
I have to see them on this goddamn Tour
all right um and I'm thinking the last
time I went to go see him is the only
time I ever saw him was the first time I
ever went to a concert and I'm sitting
there going Rob hord is 72 years old the
last time I saw him in concert he was
34 something like that no wait yeah I
was
[Applause]
18 on the uh fuel for Life Tour all
right let me let me do a little read
here um acdc's coming back out I gotta
catch them because you know a lot of
these people you you don't know if this
is their last time [__] out you know
I'm not saying they're gonna die but
they might also be like why don't I just
go out make money one more time and
[__] chill I've been around the world
a thousand [__] times do I really
need to do it a thousand in one I don't
think so all right here we go uh all
right I got a little [__] read here
oh look who it is everybody it's old
zip recruiter right now I'd like to give
a shout out to all those people whose
job it is to hire from the small
business owners growing their team to
the HR directors hiring hundreds Across
the Nation you have one of the toughest
jobs there
is all right let's let's not [__] ex
it's a pain in the ass all right I don't
think I want to be drilling for oil be
one of those guys that's just covered in
oil connecting those pipes I think I'd
rather be sitting there going like God
how do I get somebody to work the bra
uh but what if I were to tell you that
there's something that can make your
whole hiring process faster and easier
yes it's
zip um and right now you can try it for
free it's Z ziprecruiter.com bur instead
of you doing all the work instead of you
doing all the work for the hiring and
all of that bullin [__] um you just
leave it up up to zip let them do the
work for you once you post your job on
zip uh it sends it to 100 plus job sites
so you reach more of the right people
zip recruiter's powerful technology
scans thousands of resumés for you to
identify people whose skills and
experience match your job Hiring Heroes
let zip recruiter make your job easier
four to five employers who post on zip
uh get a quality candidate within the
first day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address to try zi
recruiter for free that's
ziprecruiter.com bur again that
zip recruiter.com bur spell out Burr b r
r zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire um all right well that's going to
be the podcast for today here we go
Bruins here here we go I'm
excited uh we got James Van Ry Reams
Dyke however the [__] you say it from
the
Flyers he's on our first line with
Pasto I think debrus is up on our first
line then we got chal Cole Coyle Brad M
Sean maybe that has de Brusque on that
line and then we got that kid there that
was killing
it on the uh on the third line we got
luch on the fourth line I think you know
I think we're going to be all right I
think we're going to surprise some
people you know hav't I got to be honest
with you the work that we did here you
know considering Patrice berson and
David craie retired I
mean that was
like I think other than Brad marshan
Brad Marsha might be the last guy left
from our 2011 Stanley Cup team so
um I don't know I think we could be
looking a lot worse and
uh I don't know I just love [__]
hockey I'm very excited that it's back
I'm going to enjoy it and that is it
anyway have a great weekend you [__]
and uh I will talk to you on Monday
enjoy the music and then we have a bonus
episode of the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
after the
music hey what's going on it's Bill bur
it's time for the Monday morning for
Monday uh what the hell is it October
12th 2015 what's going on how are you um
I'm recording this Sunday CU as you're
listening to this um unless I post it
tonight or who's kidding who my podcast
guy posted because I don't know how to
do it um I'll actually I got some acting
work uh Monday and Tuesday so as always
I never tell you what the hell I'm doing
because you know you can get edited out
and then you look like an [__] like
you say hey everybody look for me I'll
be that guy in that thing and then all
of a sudden you're not in it and then
everybody goes hey I thought you were
going to be in that you know laughing my
ass off epic fail actor balding
redheaded [__] you know I got to deal
with that all day so I usually don't say
anything but I'm I'm excited it's going
to be fun it's funny [__] and uh so
that's what I got to do over the next
couple of days but um so it's football
Sunday I'm recording this right as the
uh the Patriots and Cowboys game just
ended I'm not going to
gloat um I know that that was a banged
up uh Cowboys damn it come on I think
the last play of the game when you guys
your receiver beat our cornerback and
the ball still sailed like8 feet over
his [__]
head I felt bad for that was it number
83 I don't know who he is so I know he
needs those stats they all need the
stats that's how they make their money
you know the end of the season when
they're they they're uh their their
Sports uh agent comes in hey the guy not
for nothing the guy uh yeah had [__]
17 touchdowns
so after 16 that means he [__] makes
an extra four in a grand so if this guy
comes up one short you think he's not
going to be thinking about that you know
when they have the Cowboys Christmas
party and they don't make the playoffs
you don't think 83 is going to be
staring at that [__] uh that radio
contest winner that they had at
quarterback I shouldn't talk [__] about
him you know I don't know anything about
him either but um that play really made
me laugh
because after the ball goes over 83 his
head I think that's his number right you
see him yelling at the corner and the
corner is kind of laughing back at him
and you know he was going like I [__]
beat you again I should have had [__]
150 yards on you if this guy could
[__] throw it to me and the other guy
doesn't give a [__] cuz he knows in the
end right it's just going to show up on
the stat sheet who gives a [__] so
uh anyways so you know I felt bad for
the Cowboys you know what I mean snake
bitten they're just [__] snake bitten
they look like they were going to be
good Tony Roma gets hurt all that
[__] you know but uh I do think on
one level it was uh Justice by the
football gods that the patriots who some
people were suggesting you know if the
Brady suspension went through could have
been 0 and four 1 and 3 2 and two that
were actually 4 and0 I think that that
means the football Gods know that Tom
Brady did not
cheat okay oh you guys can [__] roll
your eyes and shake your heads all you
want you know what the greatest thing
about it is is I can't hear you right
now you ever think about that I can't
hear you but you can hear me so you you
have to listen to this [__] all right
you don't have to but I know if you're
listening to this [__] right now you're
probably doing something you don't want
to be doing and you need to be
distracted so all you can do is sit
there and hope that maybe it's going to
get better or you could fast forward
through it because I'm going tell you
right now I'm going to talk about this
for another couple two or three minutes
so you might want to jump ahead you know
if you're a [__] uh who the big cry
baby if you're a Colts fan you know it
sucks that Andrew Luck is hurt man I
want to go in there and I I want the
Patriots you like how he just said I
want to go in there ah [__] somebody's
at the door hold on a second hold on
hang
on all right I'm back Cleo get over
there lay down this is what happens when
you got a crazy Pitbull you got to make
sure wait wait wait wait wait you got to
close all the [__] doors so you don't
eat any buddy lay down
buddy lay down buddy all right sorry
sorry I'm I'm back I'm back dog's crazy
man dog dog is
awesome but uh she's only awesome to
like seven people and everybody else
look at her right now she's sitting in
the her bed with her ears up you know
what I mean listening intently totally
locked in that Terrier Jean
Cleo still not looking let's see how
loud I have to say her name Cleo Cleo
Cleo there we go
relax Stand
Down
um anyways I like how he said I want to
go in there I want to go into
Indianapolis and I want to sit there and
eat a [__] Sausage King CU I watch
athletes play at a professional level no
I was saying I want to uh I wanted I
wanted to see the Patriots you know go
in and play the Colts at full [__]
strength if we go in next week okay and
if we win God willing and you know
Andrew Lu not 100% so I'm not going to
gloat about that one I hate when [__]
people do that [__] you know what I mean
so uh what a what a what a leg NFL there
was so many games those 1:00 games that
I just thought were were over you know
all right Browns are getting their ass
kicks Seattle's killing [__]
Cincinnati there was one other one in
there
um Cincinnati came back the Browns came
back who else came back there was like
three [__] games in the beginning
ah Christ I can't oh the bills the bills
ended up coming back too I was watching
that game um you know Titans are young
they don't not a close out a team yet
but uh I'm always watching Rex Ryan man
I like the way that guy coaches and it's
funny to see him lose nobody takes off a
[__] headset when he loses like him
he's always good for a couple of curses
[__] [__] he tears tears the [__]
thing off but
um yeah so anyways I actually totally
got off track so I was talking about
like I liter think that uh not to make
excuses for uh how dumb I am but there
I really think there's something wrong
with the way my brain is wired the way I
when I visually look at something and
try and process it and this [__]
flyer it had it didn't have uh you know
the thing was the show was down at The
Shrine Auditorium or something like that
which I found out Led Zeppelin actually
played at um I was not in that theater
obviously I was in the I was in
basically the hallway area that led to
the arena that uh the theater I should
say that um that Zeppelin played in and
um anyways but I noticed the flyer it
completely [__] me up because at the
there was shows from basically like 3:00
in the afternoon to 12: midnight so when
they listed the shows for some reason
they started at 12: midnight and they
went backwards and then the block that I
was in was basically Largo
comics with um veroa salts band was
actually the band that you got to play
with which is [__] awesome right and
just the way they they had it like
instead of going down you know I can't
even explain it I mean would you go
[__] like five 6 7 8 you would go 12
11 right but if I had any sort of like
learning like visual ability ability I
would have just looked at it like I just
look at something like that and I just
go like when I see all of that [__] it
just my brain just goes like I can't
even [__] see
it totally turns my brain to Mush and
all I saw was
Largo so my dumbass drives to Largo now
obviously most of you don't live out
here so Largo is basically without
traffic is about 20 25 minutes away from
the Shrine Auditorium so there's always
traffic here so it was a colossal [__]
on my part and um and of course I I
didn't bring the the I had the parking
passes and The Wristband I had all of
that laid out ready to go and my brain
kept saying for days and days and days
going make sure you have that make sure
you have that and as I was getting ready
to leave I saw it on the desk I'm like
oh yeah that thing that thing and then I
[__]
go to get my keys and then I walk out
the door without the parking pass
without the
wristband driving to Largo the exact
opposite direction when I'm supposed to
go to the other [__] place it was a
uh an absolute [__] show and I really on
the way
over
um I can't bring myself to say it
because I've always said that it's just
an excuse but I would just say there's
something [__] up with the way my
brain is
wired cuz my whole life that's just like
it's like I don't think I'm dumb but I
continue to do dumb [__] so the end of
the day right it's the results that's
like say I'm a good quarterback but I
keep losing the game right so at the end
of the day yeah you suck as a
quarterback so I would love to hear you
know considering I'm not a doctor
obviously obviously I'd like to hear
your guys analysis because that's what
this whole [__] internet thing is
about the internet is about people who
have absolutely zero
qualification just chiming in with their
opinion just going on and [__] that's
what this podcast
is I haven't looked up any I don't
[__] know anything right so anyway so
I drive over to the um the venue and uh
it's [__] gigantic place it's one of
those places when they bring you into it
you don't even know what it looks like
it's so [__] big I came in from like
the parking structure and uh I get in
and I'm walking by and there's the open
area that I'm going to be on
that stage and then I walk by and then I
go by the theater that evidently LED
zeim played at and uh Reggie Watts is on
stage of course crushing it I went
upstairs I met the people in the band
and then they basically just [__] ran
through If You Want Blood and I sat
there air drumming and that's one of
those songs that Fades out so the big
thing was like all right how the [__]
are we going to end this song um and
they were like all right let's do it so
then when I came back
downstairs I'm walking by that it was
the this weird thing when you walked
behind the theater where the guy was on
stage I can't even explain
it I can't even explain it so this time
when I go
down Reggie is finishing up I walk in go
out into this Hall [__] area and then
we're in the basically the Giant open
area that looks it looks like a giant
mall after the apocalypse there was an
upper deck but there was no stores and
it wasn't really well
lit and um so anyways the show starts
Greg Baron kills TIG nataro is killing
so I'm thinking everybody's killing I
got to get my [__] together so when I
walked into the other area um to get my
head together um I looked and Super Dave
Osborne was on stage where Reggie was
just on stage and for guys my age and
older you remember him from uh that show
bizaar and I'm definitely going to I got
to put up some clips hopefully I'll
[__] remember I always say oh yeah
I'm going to put up some clips and then
I talk for another 50 minutes minutes
and I forget it but uh he was on stage
and um I would have loved to have met
that guy that guy used to [__] kill
me when I was a kid and um but anyways
Jesus Bill get to the [__] point here
so I go on stage I do my thing and
um uh tell my jokes or whatever and now
I'm going to go back and go play the
[__] drums you know when you sit down
on somebody else's kit it's like driving
somebody else's car the chair is either
too [__] close to the steering wheel
not the high hat and all that stuff so I
sit down we start [__] playing I [__]
it up from the very beginning uh not in
a bad way I'm just I'm I'm just not
playing it the way it is on the album
and I can see the guitar player looking
at me like dude what the [__] you didn't
do that upstairs so I continue doing the
same mistake but on time so you know
nobody [__] notices but he's looking
at me like wow is this going to be a
train record or at least I felt he was
it's probably my own insecurity and then
we start to play and I can't hear
anything I couldn't even hear the bass
drum and it was like wow this is I I
didn't realize that musicians have to
deal with this [__] so it's kind of cool
so I'm literally can almost hear one of
the guitarist and I'm watching his foot
and I just started humming the song in
my
head I'm just doing that it's
scal living in a human Zoo I'm just back
there humming this [__] song but it
was great they kept turning around
looking at me when we were going into
the verse so it ended up going uh going
great
but the highlight of it other than
getting to play with faruka salt which
is [__] [__] um they totally rocked
the whole [__] night right I was uh
at one point I looked up at the crowd
cuz that was one of my goals just like
was standup like I had to be like I'm
taking the mic out of the mic stand I'm
baby stepping this thing with every once
in a while playing out playing drums
right I actually was trying to look up
at the crowd more so at one point I'm
looking up to the crowd as I'm humming
the song cuz I can't I can barely hear
people
um I saw this woman in the crowd and she
was standing there she wasn't moving at
all wasn't tapping her toes wasn't
[__] nodding her head nothing and she
had this Blank Stare but she wasn't
looking at anybody she was just sort of
daydreaming standing right in the front
she was like the poster child for like
being completely disconnected to
anything that was going on stage and
when I saw her the old me that would
crushed
me cuzz I was so self-conscious about my
playing but when I saw her I actually
looked
down I just looked down and I started
laughing and uh I didn't think about it
until I was driving away when I was
critiquing the [__] out of everything I
did I was actually driving away and I I
took that that was my victory on that
one was that uh she clearly was not into
it and it didn't rattle me it actually
made me laugh and I was able to find the
humor in that and I was talking to
another comic about it and I I feel like
uh that's the difference between a
performer that stays doing it and
somebody who just after a while just
quits I'm not saying one person is
better than another but in order to
[__] do any sort of Performing you
have to find the humor in bombing or
you're [__] you have to be able to
look at somebody is you're trying your
[__] hardest and they're just sitting
there like I mean dude she was thinking
about next Wednesday or some [__] or
something from her childhood like she
was that
far in the daydreaming it was [__]
brutal and you got to be able to look at
that and just be like what I'm doing
right now made her do
that you know like that's how bad I am
right now so whatever I was able to
shake it off you know it's hopefully the
Cowboys will be able to shake off
today's loss right there did I bring it
back speaking of
losing uh my Boston Bruins my beloved
here we go Bruins here we go are um
they're 0 and two now we we got
shellacked by Winnipeg we played good
for a period and a half you know but
then again you know the game is three
periods but whatever it's a brand new
[__] team we got rid of everybody
they got to figure out how they're going
to Jael right so I'm not freaking out
yet and I don't have any you know
ridiculous expectations especially of uh
our coach clo Julian and I already heard
one guy go after we lost to Montreal he
goes you know they uh is it time to
shorten up the leash on CL Julian it's
like why why would you do that does he
suddenly not know no understand the game
of hockey why would you blame the fact
that they're 0 and2 on him this guy
coached the team when he had the players
to win
a [__] Stanley
Cup that was only four years ago it's
not like it was 40 years ago the game
hasn't passed the dude
by okay in that time we lost Tyler Sean
Johnny Boy
Chuck douge Hamilton and L che the face
of our franchise it's a whole new
[__] team when he had those guys most
of those guys I don't think douge was on
the 2011 team yet I can't remember he
won a cup
so I don't think you know if you if
you're going to [__] when they're
trying to redo the whole [__] team
after two losses if you got to [__]
about anybody you got to [__] about our
new
GM Don Sweeny that's the guy who should
take be taking the heat not the [__]
coach you know who would say [__] like
that Dan shaunessy Dan shaunessy would
say [__] like that cuz the man doesn't
watch
hockey so anyways I actually saw a lot
of positives in the um yet another loss
um to the Canadians the hated Canadians
um so many new play I mean I didn't get
to watch the Winnipeg game but Joe
bartnick from Puck off podcast told me
that uh Winnipeg is a force and that
there's no [__] shame in losing to
them and you know they're loaded which
is [__] annoying to me it's like well
how are they loaded how how are they
under the salary cap and they're [__]
loaded I don't how do they what they got
more money than us they're in [__]
Winnipeg I've been to Winnipeg all
right I don't know what the [__] you do
out there but some they got more money
than
us why cuz they're always digging a new
[__] Canal for a mall cuz it's too
cold to be outside maybe is that what it
is I don't [__] know but anyways I
saw some
uh I saw some positive [__] Jesus Christ
we had like seven penalties and to all
you Canadian fans out there I'll admit
we were guilty of all of them I didn't
have a problem with any of the calls um
even the five minute one that spoon it
took right that gave him the game
misconduct uh I didn't have a problem
with any of those Carrie Price looked
[__] great and uh but you know other
than the first penalty kill which we
look like a beer league team um you know
we killed off all those including a
fivem minute major at one point we were
when uh what's his face
um
um good Lord Bill what is wrong with
your brain right now Brad marshan Jesus
Christ he took a penalty we actually had
a five on three they had a five on three
for a minute we still killed that we had
a goal called back I didn't have a
problem with that either we laying on
the dude's mask but uh I don't know I
didn't think we were bad we were
competitive I'll give us that so I'm
sticking it
out I'm watching every game we got Tampa
Bay next we probably lose to that
one you know I don't
know as bartnik told me we got to beat
the bad teams and [__] hang in there
and uh who knows we've gotten rid of
everybody I got to
think that we have some salary cap uh
money left over that maybe we can pick
some somebody up or something I don't
[__] know I don't know what they're
doing but don't blame the [__] coach
for the love of God we don't even have
Chara Chara is out right now um but I
like that number 39 kid that we got from
the ducks that uh how do you say his
name Matt boleski or whatever he looks
good pastor knock is going to be great I
think we got some [__] got some [__]
right K's healthy c g Patrice berser on
you know I think it'll be
okay um whatever I'm not gonna be one of
those guys that [__] [__] moans and
complains all right we did we did fine
did fine those first two games I'm still
going to watch him you know is if they
keep playing the way that they're
playing I'm I'm all right with it I can
handle that as long as whatever Don
Sweeney is doing is leading towards the
light you know actually Maran took a
[__] elbow to the head at the end of
the game I think he's got a concussion
that's brutal one of our best [__]
guys right and uh I don't think it was
deliberate you never know but I just
think the guy was so much taller than
him he was just trying to do the contact
thing um you see this people this is
like actually seeing both sides of it I
did that with the Patriots I'm doing it
with the Bruins right I am being a model
sports fan right now you like that you
probably don't cuz it's probably not as
funny you really want me to [__] go
off on some [__] is that is that what
you want I'll tell you what I'm going to
go off on like I actually uh I'm I felt
bad for
McDonald's you know first of all this
whole excitement that they're trying to
create about the fact that they're
serving breakfast all day I mean I might
be out of the loop you know I'm an older
fellow but nobody I knew I know is has
ever [__] that McDonald's doesn't serve
breakfast all day they might [__] you
know when you show up at 10:31 are you
still serving breakfast no I'm sorry you
know and you got a hangover and you just
want one of their [__] sausage egg
and cheese and now you got to get like a
quarter
pounder you know something about the
eggs you know you I got to eat some eggs
in there little bit of biscuit right I
can see that and I can see them hey from
now now on we're going to be serving uh
breakfast until 11:00 a.m. that would
have been fine but to watch these guys
just cave
in to their fan base and just say you
know what okay you know what you guys
you win you win you can have breakfast
all day long to watch them do that it's
like watching a great artist just
completely sell out
right and just start you know making
songs that really meant something and
connected with you to just you remember
that time when Brian Adams put on the
eyeliner and spiked up his [__] hair
just like how would how did the summer
69 guy go from this to that what what
happen that's what McDonald's is doing
right now they got their eyeliner on
they got their [__] hair all spiked
up they might as well just you know when
they announced that they [__] going
to do breakfast all day they might as
well have had Ronald McDonald behind two
turntables pretending to be like a
DJ you
know have a little self-esteem
McDonald's don't [__] give it to
these [__] animals [__] them if you
can't roll your fat ass out of bed by 10
or 10:30 you're getting a burger all
right [__] you going to make eggs for
your all goddamn day I'm not [__]
Burgers like 99 Cents what more could we
be doing for you could we doing for you
what more could we be doing for you see
that that's that [__] hiccup in my
brain um I think it's a bad move you
don't see Wendy's doing that Wendy's
doesn't even serve breakfast they're
like [__] you we make hamburgers and you
know what they're square deal with it
right McDonald's you're the dealer
You're The Pusher okay you let the
junkies come to you you don't start
slashing prices okay I okay you you
[__] billions and billions have
served the formula [__] works what
are they so afraid
of because I'll tell you right now you
know what sucks Denny's let's just talk
breakfast food right here you know
Denny's [__] blows I don't know what
it is about them they are like like IHOP
is like the iro Z and Denny's is just
the the regular you got a Camaro but
it's got a V6 in it I don't know why
they serve the exact
same the exact same they almost have the
same menu they just call it different
[__] right it's like McDonald's and
McDonald's right but there's some about
IHOP you know that their pancakes
they're more fluffier
Bacon's a little more crispier I like
their toast
better you know eggs or eggs
whatever you know don't ever order
scrambled eggs if you want scrambled
eggs you make them yourself okay they
just nobody knows how to make [__]
scrambled eggs nobody knows how to make
oatmeal they know how to make oatmeal
but they made it like N9 hours ago and
they just stick it in a giant vat I'll
give you guys a great tip on [__]
when you make scrambled
eggs all right when you scramble them
you got to scramble the [__] out of them
all right when I scramble eggs all right
put two or three in the bowl okay it's
like a cooking show except you're
listening to it right um You [__] you
know how the hell I even got on this
subject how the [__] does this happen
I'm telling you guys how to scrambled
eggs do you realize how insulted you
should be right now this is like
something you tell a 5-year-old but this
is a little secret that I made scrambled
eggs forever and you know what they
tasted like the scrambled eggs at
Denny's and I was proud I was like these
are just like the ones that Denny's but
I didn't realize that Denny's absolutely
sucked
right so um I'm just loving all the
tweets I'm going to get because you know
there's people out there that love
Denny's and thinks IHOP stinks I will
tell you this Denny's table's not as
sticky IHOP has cornered the [__]
Market I mean dude you put your elbow on
that table if you leave it there for
more than 3 seconds I mean somebody's
got to get a putty knife for you're not
getting it off there um so anyways the
the the scrambled eggs this is what you
want to do right you put two or three in
a bow whatever you want to [__]
do all right then you take out your fork
and you start [__] scrambling them
and what a lot of people do is they
scramble them for like [__] you know
15 20 seconds tops you don't want to do
that dude you want to scramble them for
like 2 minutes you want to get a bunch
of air in there you want to scramble the
[__] out of them right I learned this
from read an article on James con one
time he he gave you those tips so this
is from him so if you think I'm a
[__] [__] I'm going from a guy who
was in Godfather one and two all right
and
elf three of the greatest [__] movies
of all time as far as I'm concerned all
right so anyways you got to get that air
in there you got to have those bubbles
going right over the top you know what I
mean like a good milkshake that's what
the [__] it should look like meanwhile
you got your pan your pan is on hi I
know you guys Christ you're going to
cook the [__] out of it no what you're
going to do is the second you pour it in
you're going to be constantly moving
that [__] right you put it in
the right you got the pan you got your
little [__] whatever you use
right your olive oil whatever the [__]
you I wouldn't put butter in there
because you got it on high right
whatever you spray in there your Pam
whatever you whatever you use to deplete
the ozone layer you get that thing on
high right and right as whatever you put
in there just starts to see like it's
going to start smoking you pour that
[__] in there and it
goes and then you move that [__]
around like a stir fry you don't stop
moving that thing right and when it
looks like it's about halfway done
you pull the frying pan off the burner
and you finish it that way then you take
it you [__] dump it on and you're
done that's it oh at some point you put
some sea salt in there too what however
however you want to garnish it all right
and I'm telling you they'll be nice and
fluffy all right unlike that horeshit
that they have down there at Denny's and
IHOP IHOP doesn't make good scrambled
eggs either then you got to get cheese
in them you got to get cheese but that's
like ordering a steak and you got to put
like [__] A1 on it because the guy
didn't know how to cook it you should
not have to put cheese in your [__]
scrambled eggs if you know what you're
doing all right and you know what that's
one to grow on there you go how was that
took me [__] 78 years of doing this
podcast and I finally told you how to
scramble a goddamn
egg um actually you know something the
cooking it on high part and then taking
it off I learned that from Nia she
taught me that thing Jesus Christ we're
already [__] halfway through this
thing let me uh let me do some of the
reads here for this
week how a scramble an egg what a
[__] [__]
Jesus that must you should really you
should really be [__]
offended you should be offended right
now cuz I'm not really even apologizing
to you I'm just killing time while I try
and find where the [__] I put the
advertising oh here we go all right
Jesus that was great got those right out
of the way got them right out of the way
okay now where am I going
here oh Jesus I always have like 9
million things opened at the same time
here why do I do that to myself oh by
the way somebody sent me uh a link to
some [__] music I only listen to a
couple of their songs but I really liked
them I don't know how to say the name of
the band it's g o j i r a goira goira go
I have no idea it's the name of the
album is from Mars to
sirius and uh I usually don't like that
music where the people sing like that
death metal [__] but these [__] guys
ladies men and women I don't know what
the [__] they are they sound like
they're a bunch of guys um the album
blew me way the song did anyway it's
called the heaviest matter of the
Universe um I downloaded the album came
out in 2006 so uh I'm a little late to
the party there but um I want to thank
whoever sent me that um giving me the
heads up cuz I really enjoyed that song
and I immediately went and downloaded
the entire freaking album over there um
all right what are we up to here 34
minutes all right I'm going to do a
couple more Cleo and then I'm going to
do the questions and then we're going to
get out of here all right that doesn't
mean you need to come over here all
right thank you
thank you for the kisses don't be needy
get out of here go over there and lay
down go on get over there Cleo please
get over there thank you go on lay
down there you go you got your own
[__] couch how much more could you be
spoiled you know what it is was today I
watched like the whole I watched the
Bills game the Browns and the Bengals
game I was just clicking around with a
little bit of the Packers too and I had
the whole house to myself and I was just
laying on the couch and she was up on
the couch with me laying there like a
[__] baby so now she wants the whole
day like that you know what I mean she's
a spoiled brat hey did you guys see the
latest uh that FanDuel thing where they
got Tiki Barber and uh Ronde Barber two
NFL players talking about it and I F you
know how yeah just pick out your [__]
day and pick up your cash my favorite
thing there was a guy on
there where he this guy worked on Wall
Street he's crushing it pilfering from
the greatest generation right they're
too dumb to know what's going at this
point they don't know what's going on in
their portfolios stealing from old
people stealing from young people licens
to steal the man is on Wall Street
there's nobody watching these [__]
every once in a while they throw a
celebrity chef in jail to make it look
like they're actually paying attention
this guy was on [__] Easy Street and
for some dumb reason according to this
infomercial he just
decides out of the [__] blue to to
quit his job and try to win a million
dollars on
FanDuel I love that like you you just
can't try that on the weekend you got to
sit there and stare at [__]
stats seven days a [__] for six days
before you make your pick so long story
short the guy goes out he's in the
infomercial so you know he's not going
to lose and you know what he goes out
and he wins he wins a million bucks and
you know what he does you know what he
does [__] that he is you know what
he does True Romance
he [__] quits his job I'm supposed to
believe that this guy that works on Wall
Street quited quit quitted quit his
[__] sixf fig
job on Wall Street to make a million
dollar I know some of you [__] you
know peons on Wall Street are going to
be like oh you know I just started I
only make 30 grand a year I don't give a
[__] about you there baby face two
whiskers I don't give a [__] about you
all right you sociopath you're going to
work your way up this guy was like my
age and he was almost as bald as I am
all right so if he's still on Wall
Street he's making money all right he's
got a [__] you know a goddamn ulcer
in his stomach okay so I know this guy's
making money so whatever I don't even
know I don't know if he [__] work
Works on Wall Street what the [__] do I
know so anyways he says that he quit his
job after he made the million he quit
his job he quit his job on Wall Street
cuz he won a million dollars on FanDuel
which which after
taxes is is going to be more than 50%
tax bracket so let's say he gets to keep
about 480 85 Grand after he's done
[__] you know paying his account and
all the other [__] you know what I
mean buying his [__] wife the pink
Cadillac or the fur coat get it out of
here get it out take it back get what
matter with you what's matter with you
right once he's done doing all that
right he's got like [__] 480
Grand he quits his [__] job and now
he's going to take that 480 Grand and
reinvest in his new business of gambling
on
football this [__] guy is going to be
homeless he's going to be homeless with
I'm that's what I'm calling him right
now this guy's going to be destitute and
[__] he's going to be one of the guys
that Bryant Gumble interviews or
actually one of his peons interviews you
know what I mean he always sends them
out
Bryant is not going out on in the field
anymore he's too old for that [__] you
know and then you come back and he does
his followup where he has his little
clipboard of questions you know and the
person sits down and he comes back and
then he just goes like
whatever the [__] he says you know his
really high pitched voice when he's got
that little
like
um they're going to interview this
[__]
guy he's going to sit there you and
Bryant interview somebody and he just
thinks that they're the dumbest [__] on
the planet he does he does not he wears
his emotions not on his sleeve he wears
them right on his [__] face I never
understood that why why is it your
sleeve nobody looks at your sleeve when
you're talking I don't get what that
means I've never understood it nor did I
ever look it up considering I got a
[__] I got a goddamn uh laptop right
here why don't I look it up come on
window move for
me we got two defenseman on the Bruins
right now last name
Miller dude what [__] Miller you
talking about well there's [__] two
of them they're both defensemen Colin
and [__]
Kevin same names as my cousins
um hey did anybody watch the Gas Monkey
Garage where they did that [__] 78
O's cutless what a [__] great car I'm
not the biggest fan of low riders but uh
those paint jobs are [__] ridiculous
I think they look cool as [__] but I'm
I'm just I like I like going fast more
than just [__] cruising around but uh
the 78 Ol cutless Man is [__] those
were the cars man when I was a kid man
from like the like the late 70s to like
the old
cutless the the Chevy mon Carlo and the
Buick Regal they were basically all the
same body stpe body type and I thought
that those were the best looking stock
cars too right Harry Gant the skull
Bandit kale yarber darl wal
trip right back when what's his face uh
uh Dale nhart rest his soul used to
drive the Wrangler the blue and yellow
Wrangler he get out there he get
sideways right they all had old they had
cutlasses Monte
Carlos I think Harry G had the [__]
uh I think he had a Grand Prix that had
that [__] the the rear window was
just straight wasn't even trying to be
aerodynamic just chopped it right down
the back things were [__] badass cars
man those twodo
CPS with that ridiculous [__]
interior that totally cheesy uh you know
where it all goes into the button that
plug interior those [__] cars were
the [__] so they redid one you know what
kills me the [__] gas monkey season
is already
over 10 episodes how the [__] does it go
by that
quick that was a brutal season for me
everybody brutal season it went by in
[__] two seconds and KC left the show
um I don't know I wish that they had let
him do more [__] like the I love when he
did the lace top and when he was trying
to do the low rider stuff um he was
talking about how when they they put so
many layers of paint on it that it looks
like you can actually after a while it
creates the illusion you feel like you
can actually reach down into it how
[__] killer is that and just watching
how
they I don't know I have such a [__]
respect for that they did so many cool
projects this year where they try to do
something different they did the old
caddy they did a low rider they got that
Ford
GT um such a great [__] season and I
you know I know that that show's the
best man it just went went by too
[__] fast now what am I going to do
right I had the same level of depression
when like a [__] Sports season ends
and they're like tune in next week for
the final episode of this season's Gas
Monkey Garage I was like what the [__]
are you talking about they just started
probably because I binged watched like
five of them because I was on the road
whatever what the [__] am I talking
about oh wearing your emotions on your
sleeve hey guys I'm getting better at
that huh I usually go off on a tangent I
never come
back wearing his oh [__] that [__] his
or her wearing emotions typing with just
my index finger on
sleeve
definition meaning no origin that's what
I want the origin origin of wearing your
heart on your sleeve oh that's how you
say it not your
emotions uh Come on load please
advertising oh look at that pretty girl
with her she lotions healthy looking
skin starts here with
youthin continue our site that was it I
just had to look at her she was nice to
look at the origins of wearing your
heart on your
sleeve all right here we go it was
during the Roman Empire that St
Valentine is said to have left a note to
his jailer's
daughter oh Jesus how much was she
trying to [__] piss off her dad by
[__] one of the inmates huh from your
Valentine uh before his execution
on February 14th today thanks to St
Valentine cards expressing one's
heartfelt emotions AKA Valentines are
given to that special
someone to defer to the classic idiom
it's a day to wear your heart on your
sleeve was there an explanation in there
you started with the story and then you
just deferred which completely [__] me
up we use the phrase casually to mean
exposing our true emotions making
ourselves vulnerable and letting it all
hang out
the phrase is so pervasive that from
Ringo Star to Eminem to carry underw
those words to turn into dude are you
trying to stretch this out any longer
this could have been one [__]
paragraph wearing your heart on a sleeve
oh here we go but what kind of sleeve
and why on a sleeve I swear to God I'm
reading the copy and not pants or legs
and around your neck there's no clear
answer you [__]
[__] but many you [__] dick that's
why you were stretch it out cuz if you
just wrote I don't know I wouldn't have
clicked on your
site all right we got to see it through
people I'm sorry there's no clear answer
but many Legends attempt to to get at
the
heart of the matter now you're going to
go into a pun after you tell me this is
such a [__] train wreck I can't stop
it may explain the source of the saying
the three most popular are in the Middle
Ages Emperor Claudius II believed
unattached men made better soldiers so
he declared marriage illegal as a
concession he encouraged temporary
coupling once a year during a Roman
Festival honoring Juno men drew names to
determine who would be their
lady friend for the coming year once
established the man would wear a name on
his sleeve for the rest of the
festival Jesus Christ did the woman have
any
say no she's just a common
HOA Janet Rossy is a h uh around that
same time it speculated when a night
performed in a jousting match in the
king's court he dedicated his
performance to a woman of the Court by
tying something of hers like a
handkerchief around his arm he let the
court know the match would defend the
honor of that woman or we can credit
Shakespeare and I'm not reading this
shakes you want to hear me read
Shakespeare where May okay
IO it is sure as you are Ro Rod rodri
rodero were I the more I would be I
would not be I
ago well I'm glad you cleared that up
Billy this is right here why I flunked
all this [__] and following him I follow
but my ah dude [__] you [__] you all
right Jesus Christ why don't you Jesus
[__] Christ that you know how
depressing that was that [__] attempt
right
there it's amazing it's amazing I
succeed in anything isn't it um oh by
the way they were doing this 20-year
retrospective on o the OJ Simpson trial
it was funny and they said the exact
same [__] that they said 20 years ago
how polarizing it was and how white
people saw it one way and how black
people saw it another way now obviously
I'm not going to be dumb enough to try
to speak for black people here I
wouldn't do that but I'll tell you what
there was plenty of black people on that
show speaking for white people and you
know I'm not saying they were 100% wrong
but they were never speaking for all the
sports fans out there who happen to be
white like me the whole trial when I was
watching that I was never thinking oh
that son of a [__] black guy killed
that pure blond white woman I never
thought that [__] the entire trial I
thought the exact same thing anytime I
would turn it on I would think the exact
same thing I would be like that is
[__] OJ
Simpson OJ Simpson is sitting behind
that table on trial for a double murder
I grew up watching that guy you know
when he did the Herz commercials I was
just I was like five or six years old
that old lady Go OJ go right when he
would [__] jump over the the luggage
I wasn't old enough to know that a black
guy starring in a [__] commercial
like that was
groundbreaking I didn't I just knew that
that guy was [__] awesome he had a
cool nickname my first pack of football
cards I got Cleo for the love of [__]
Christ can you lay down buddy all right
get up here get up here there you go lay
down see I give in I give in cuz you're
so cute anyways back to
OJ um my first pack of football cards
that I got he was right on top
right on [__] top I think the gum was
in the back so it didn't ruin it and um
that was like my prize possession and I
remember I was so young when he got
traded to the 49ers and I got that Topps
football card that me and my brothers
used to call sidee because everything
was on when we used to trade like what
year flag year side year football year
um rather than the years um I thought it
was going to be worth money because he
was on a different team like wow this is
OJ Simpsons on the 49ers this is is
going to be worth money cuz people you
know I didn't realize that the rookie
card I was young I was stupid and then I
watched his [__] movies The Naked Gun
I watched him on Monday Night Football
when he was with Joe namoth and he would
be like you know what I would have done
right there I would have cut back he
used to say what he would do and then
Joe neth would always say the same thing
that was a really nice play play he used
always say that [__] and it was a
terrible year for Monday Night Football
whatever I just remember hearing [__]
that Bob cus and Al Michaels you know
weren't in with them anymore I just it
was the first time I really remember
watching
somebody have it all and then [__]
lose it all and it was always that's how
I always looked at him OJ Simpsons 2003
[__] yards in a season Heisman Trophy
winner star of the Naked Gun one and two
and that [__] movie where he was the
astronaut
right and the thing goes bad and then
they try to kill him that's who the [__]
he was and there he was just sitting
there on trial I couldn't [__]
believe
it so the next time they do one of those
documentaries they got to have a dope
like me in
there not going like you know in the
history and the justice system black
people have always SE the white person
get up tell me it was it was [__] it
was OJ Simpson all right for you
youngsters out there just to who who's
your
guy you know what I mean is there even a
guy like that anymore I don't
I can't relate to it anymore because
every time I look at an athlete now it's
just somebody half my [__] age living
a dream that never happened to
me um it's [__] ridiculous all right
where the [__] are we here let me get to
let me get to some of the reads for the
week here and then I'm going to go
workout cuz I go to the gym every day um
I'm maintaining guys I put on a few then
I take it off put on a few take it off
but I'm still in my fight and [__]
weight um which I don't even know what
the [__] it is anymore which is good cuz
I got acting work tomorrow so maybe I'll
look sexy and maybe I'll get some more
work out of it I don't know where the
[__] is oh did I close the wrong
one a Jesus can this be like a new
segment on the [__] podcast where
Bill tries to find the [__] window
that he opened and everything was fine
and he had it all set up and then he
[__] it up when he's on live all right
content content hey if you guys want to
email the podcast uh Bill themmm
podcast.com
all right DraftKings inside Insider
explanation all right cuz I didn't get
it last week I didn't understand why it
was such a big [__] deal that some
people from DraftKings won 300 Grand at
FanDuel and they were saying that they
had inside information it's I was like
what do you what are you friends what
what you friends with a player um so
Bill not trying to be a [__] here just
explaining why that guy from DraftKings
what he did was considered Insider
information and made money basically he
had access to the percentage of
ownership of the players for example he
knew knew that 58% of people were
starting Brady 133% were starting
Russell wil Wilson 80% start uh starting
Julio Jones Etc obviously these are not
the real percentage it's just an example
well even if they were I wouldn't be
able to figure out the math so thank you
for giving me round numbers anyways he
and O and uh only others at Draft Kings
had that information not anyone else the
general meaning the general public um
that were playing in those games the
numbers are released after the lineups
are locked but he had them
beforehand okay so I understand that he
had information but I don't understand
what you do with the information cuz I
don't play Fantasy Football or do this
[__] so hopefully you'll break it down a
little more he and the uh um player
percentage owned is potentially the
biggest Factor when picking players why
this is why is this
significant dude please don't ask the
questions just [__] give me the
answers why I don't know well the only
way to actually make money and get ahead
of other players is if you had different
people starting than them right if 80%
of the people are starting Julio Jones
and you have him you won't get ahead of
people you'll be even with them yeah but
if Julio has a bigger day you're going
to be
[__] so what this [__] did was look at
the players with the lowest percentage
owned that also had the highest
potential oh to have big games he used
this Insider information he had at
DraftKings to play in Big Money
tournaments at Fan duel also he won big
money almost every day playing MLB
fantasy it's not out of the question to
think he could have had information from
Shark his buddies are the highest bidder
oh well that's very
interesting that's really fascinating
that's going to be a great movie right
that's going to be one one of those
Facebook movies you know some awkward
guy is going to play the awkward guy
that started it no cool does anybody
cool who's [__] you know can hold up
their end of a conversation ever
starting think it's like a really
introverted thing this computer stuff
it's amazing they can't can't talk to
people yet what they make speaks to so
many wow sorry
uh there must have been a collective
though Jesus on that one all right NFL
pink dear Billy
Shram uh if a guy like Phil Sims Jim
Nance or Chris Collins were spoke out
about extortion involved in the breast
cancer awareness pink campaign would
they lose their job of course if they
said it's stupid they just lose their
job but if they articulated the problem
with parading survivors on the field at
the beginning of the game like during
the New England Dallas game uh while
only giving Pennies on the dollars to
the actual cause would they come under
Fire or be praised thanks go I think
I've answered all of those questions
um look I mean the NFL is always going
to sell jerseys so they make some pink
ones and the pink ones they give 8%
evidently allegedly to uh the cancer
people uh the awareness people and then
they give 8% of that 8% I don't know how
[__]
works I mean it's better than
nothing yeah I mean I think the the way
they presented it like a portion of the
proceeds fans all we hear is like oh I
buy this jersey and then they give all
this money you know I get a Jersey it's
not the color I wanted but it's going to
help out people that are
suffering um so yeah it's not it's not
the most
transparent adverti he gives a [__]
right they don't give a [__] they didn't
give a [__] when Ray Rice [__]
knocked out his fiance they only gave
him two [__] games and they didn't
give a [__] until the video came out
then they suspended him forever they
didn't give a [__] why it's because Ray
Rice [__] was making him a bunch of
money that's like you know that they
call it the Brady rule about not hitting
low and hitting the quarterback late
it's not the Brady rule it's the [__]
money rule they don't give a [__] about
Tom Brady Tom Brady makes some money if
Tom Brady's not playing they lose money
so they're like we got to protect that
[__] not cuz Tom has any sort of
influence although he is pretty dreamy
to look at uh
lifeguard Bill I'm a lifeguard in a
strong
swimmer I was at the beach last week and
I noticed a body go under oh my god oh
my god dude that's one of the scariest
[__] that's one of my biggest fears
in life the undertoe was bad that day
and I had a bad feeling so I swam to
where I thought someone went under I
pulled up an 11-year-old kid he had
water in his lungs and was struggling
dude this better be true because I or
you better go into writing because I'm
riveted right now I didn't need to give
him give full-on CPR but I did have to
administer the proper response to get
him to cough out the water he wasn't
small and he wasn't being stupid that's
just the way the ocean is the next day
the newspaper tried to interview me I
really didn't want to every time someone
does something and they're in the paper
for it it feels like a celebration it's
not someone could have died I understand
that I may have done something great are
you doing the a Shucks thing is this
like a humble brag I've been told that I
just don't want to celebrate the
reporter said that I was doing a dis
disservice because I was preventing the
story from being
inspiring do they need my sound bite can
can't the story be enough am I an
[__] no you're not you're not an
[__] at
all just [__] you do what you do and
then [__] them [__]
them yeah let them figure out what the
[__] happened
I don't think you are I don't think
you're being an [__] at all uh you
know if you're telling the truth and
you're actually actually being honest
right now you didn't use your name so
you're not going to get any praise I
think what you do I think what you did
was great yeah I don't need to [__]
talk to you I don't we ain't supposed to
talk around about talk about how [__]
great you
are I saw him go under and I knew if I
didn't get out there if I didn't do
something nobody
would um no I think you know especially
this day and age when Jesus Christ
sucking going a dick at you a TV show
you actually save somebody from drowning
I
mean probably get a [__]
miniseries actually is that better than
a TV series well most TV series don't
get picked up I don't know actually you
just get a pilot is what you really
get all right bill you done yeah I'm
done all right my girlfriend wants to
sell her panties
online how do you not read this I don't
I you guys I don't give a [__] if these
are real or not these are very
entertaining hey Billy beef farts uh I
what that means my situation is exactly
what it sounds like last week my
girlfriend of 6 years asked me if I
think it's okay if she sells her used
panties online gross to some of those
weirdo fetishes who enjoys that kind of
[__] I said sure thinking what's the
harm but what if one of those guys is in
those is a forensic expert and that's
also his [__] you know and that's how
he kind of be you know going all those
murder scenes he started sniffing
panties now he's afraid he's going to
get caught so he orders them online
then after a while the smell isn't
enough so he starts dusting the panties
for Prince and next thing know he's
standing at your door with a [__]
meat cleaver and a heart on and you
answer the door you know he's got one
hammer for one he's got the axe for the
other and you show up that's going
through your [__] head then he's look
going in looking for your pantyless
girlfriend I think you're [__] nuts
anyways I said sure thinking what's the
H we're both University students she
needs money and what's the harm in
milking these wackos for old pantties
stained in clam juice dude there's no
way you love this woman um here's the
problem she tells me that she needs to
have pictures taken in these panties to
Pro to prove to her potential clients
that she did actually wear them no she
doesn't they want to smell them so they
see her so they
can [__] rub them
out
um when she told me this I wasn't really
it wasn't really in a way that was
asking for permission not that I would
expect her to not that I would expect
her to this is how much the the [__]
American male has been beaten down that
if they don't let the woman in their
life do every [__] thing that she
every
[__] [__] idea that comes to her
head if they get in the way of it
they're crushing her dream how about
every if you're
[__] you're not even her boyfriend at
this point you're just an Entourage
member just going hey where are we going
tonight oh that's
cool can you you be a fellow do you love
this woman don't [__] let her do this
this is a dumb [__] idea don't you
have dumb ideas doesn't she say to you
every once in a while hey that's a
stupid idea and then afterwards you're
like Jesus Christ what was I thinking
thank God you're in my life this is when
you need to step up not stand
down she just dude if she [__] does
this she's basically she's in the porno
industry her picture's going to be
online on a panty sniffer [__]
website
wh what [__] job do you get after
that and it and it lives
forever and they'll wait they'll wait
till she's running for office you know
or she starts her own [__] campaign
to stop some [__] disease right then
that thing's going to come out the old
Patty panty sniffer [__] photo is
going to come out anyways he says but
more of of anyways not that I would
expect her
to dude what the what if
the what if you dabbled into the porn
industry however the [__] you were going
to do it was just a
picture huh I don't it's [__] crazy
anyways but more of a this would be part
of the deal kind of way she brought it
up to up to me immediately I tell her
that I have a huge problem with this
well all right then all right then you
scared me there earlier and she should
not be doing it she argues that and I
quote I like the attention it
gets all right dude you know what this
is the sound of be beep beep beep beep
beep beep
[Music]
beep that is the sound of you backing up
the dump truck that she's laying in the
back of and dumping that [__] in the
trash dude this is not the mother you
kids this H God bless her I don't know
who the [__] [__] her up it's it's
over
out it's over Dude it's
out it's done I I don't even need to
read the rest of this he goes like what
the [__] am I supposed to do here I beep
beep that's what you're supposed to do
keep my mouth shut and act like a cuck
holder or fight this thing to The Bitter
End I know it's her body and she has the
right to do anything with it shut the
[__] up with that Jesus Christ these
[__] feminists you guys have turned
into
zombies this isn't like a date rape
situation here
I she does have the right to do it but
you're stopping her from getting into
the porn
industry but it makes me feel like a
complete tool it should any input would
be appreciated bill I think I told you I
think I told you what you should do dude
just yeah you know
what this is the deal okay even if she
goes you're going to break up with me
well then forget it I won't do it I
can't live without you [__] that
whatever this is this this is a this is
going to rear its [__] head again I
like the attention it
gets she likes that kind of attention
Okay I'm telling you right now dude I'm
telling you right
now somebody that likes that kind of
[__] of attention if it's not the
attention that she can get within a
[__] one-on-one monog monogamous
relationship all right now whether
she'll ever act on it and go even
further end up on a poll or blowing
somebody behind a dumpster down at a
Denny's after she ate some bad scrambled
egg
who's the [__] know all you know is
that you're rolling the DI with with
half of your [__] if you ever marry this
kid this this kid this woman and have
kids you know and the kids are going to
halfway [__] look like
her oh dude I'm just flying down the
road with this
thing dumper dude dumper that's a deal
breaker I'm sorry that's a [__] deal
breaker done over all right just be like
listen uh we've come to a fork in the
road and uh you want to be a model for a
panty sniffing website which I totally
respect and uh I would like to be with
somebody that I can
trust you know who doesn't need the
attention of some of the [__]
weirdest people on the
internet
okay good luck and thank you for playing
now have you guys ever listened to the
uh the all things comedy podcast that I
I do live with uh Al Madrigal you ever
listen to those Al Madrigal
okay he's a very busy man so he might
not have time to give you breakup advice
Al Madrigal has the greatest way how you
break up with a woman that you if you're
not living with this
woman the greatest way ever and I'm
giving him full credit here and he's
already told the story on a podcast so I
don't feel like I'm overstepping my
bounds here this is the greatest way
ever this is what he would do when he
did knew that he was going to break up
with a woman and and and and uh women
can do this too he would and the woman
was not living with him he would gather
up all of her [__] that was in the
apartment and he would put it in a box
he' call her up said I need to come over
there and talk to you he'd come over
with the Box tell her it was over and
then he would [__] leave and then
there was nothing else there was no
reason for her to come back and that was
it that's what you need to do with her
you need to pack up all her panties that
she's going to be selling and modeling
soon so she can become a [__] jerk
off model
okay and she's free to do that cuz it's
her body snap 12 to 6 right is that what
they do that's her [__] body it's her
right she's an independent woman Beyonce
the whole [__] thing feminism yeah
I'm doing this [__] have fun sweetheart
right she's going to go become a jerk
off model and if you stay with her you
will become a jerk off and you don't
want to do that cuz eventually it's
going to breed resentment and uh you
know dude like it's going to be over you
can't marry her you can't [__] marry
her it's done it's [__] over it's
going to get out then your neighbor
going to find out then your neighbors
are going to be jerking off to her and
then you're going to get a
nickname you know it's it it's [__]
over God help you if you name starts
with p right Peter Paul any of that [__]
that that's the alliteration with panny
I don't know what the [__] it's going to
be but it's it's going to be a
[__] nightmare jerk off Jerry I don't
know what the [__] it's going to be but
dude you need to get out
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast for the NFL
Edition going into week number six how
the heck is everybody doing we have
another great show of picks today it was
an interesting week but first before we
get into the show we have to shout out
our great sponsor the bed MGM people the
bed MGM app the best one out there guys
uh you know how it works by now uh all
you got to do is put $10 in okay a
minimum of $10 and you will get up to
$200 in wages regardless of the outcome
of your first wager regardless
regardless it's a very rest his soul who
Freddy SoDo do his dad oh rest rest his
soul um all you guys have to do is
download the betmgm app okay use our
code for the show which is bur 200
that's that's right very simple buur
r200 put $10 in you'll get up to $200 in
Wagers uh regardless of the outcome of
the BET okay please bet responsibly and
also they're still doing you can still
get in to their uh Survivor pool which
is no spread you just pick a team that's
gonna win as long as that team wins that
week that team will be eliminated from
your list then you go to another team
the next week and as long as you stay in
there if you win it in the end you will
still get some prizes there you go bet
MGM bet responsibly have fun with it a
minimum of two uh a minimum of $10 in up
to $200 of wages regardless of your
first bet bonus
code 200 now I can't hear that word and
not think about him the the anything
better podcast did very very well this
week we went uh I went three in one bill
went two and two I know Andrew and and
Jake the Snake they throw their bets in
everybody everybody's picks last week
did pretty good all right you know was
handsome last week Paul was your record
Paul verie if if you want excitement you
got to watch Paul ver this it's gonna be
a bloodbath either way I mean it's like
the corales Castillo fight he's going oh
and one and three three and one you [__]
you guys are just grabbing the Wheel
from each other I'm [__] steady yey
yeah two and two two and two two and two
win some lose some yeah you're still two
games over though you're two games over
I'm two games under
um I'm nine and 11 and you are 11 and
you are 11 and nine um dude I got to
tell you guys something since we're on
this show here uh last night I performed
at Gotham Comedy Club for the Willie
cologne Foundation Willie cologne played
for the Patriots the Jets and he won a
Super Bowl with the Steelers when
rothberger threw that last second pass
to uh Santonio Holmes uh In The End Zone
against the Cardinals he was so they had
this thing him and his wife came out it
was for Lupus dude Bart Scott was in
there Nick Mangold of the Jets was in
there dude 10 feet in front of me CC
Sabathia dude I had CC Sabathia oh dude
I was like CCE I don't even care about
stand up man just come to the Yankees
we're a mess we need you he's laughing
right so so anyway I'm on stage and I
did the ne you know there's a big thing
going on in New York about Evan Neil the
offensive uh Giants offensive lineman
who said yeah keep booing me you think I
care he goes a lion doesn't care about a
lamb he goes you animals up there are
you know you think I care you you're
flipping burgers and hot dogs and I'm
living my dream right so everyone's
going like you know the new can I tell
you something I loved every second of
that dude and the New York media went
nuts so last night I go guys I gotta
talk about something and this place is
littered with NFL players NFL fans and I
go you know I'm a New York football
Giants fan and they started going nuts
and some people started screaming Jets
right and I said you know Evan Neil said
this and everybody's waiting and I just
go and as a Nick I said and as a giant
fan who sits up there with those people
I go he is absolutely right [__] those
people dude and it was and Willie colog
and I was they go keep going oh dude it
was the best it was the best yeah
because you know what it is for some
reason uh athletes have to treat the
crowd with 100% respect you know the
reason it's the money the NFL some shut
up well the crowd treats him with no
respect like you know I understand that
they shouldn't have been throwing stuff
but you know there's no reason to go
into the crowd there's absolutely a
[__] reason somebody throws something
at you as a professional athlete you
should be able to go out and beat the
[__] out of that guy in his [__]
water balloon body yeah absolutely
should that would stop that
behavior and if you wanted to stop the
rude Behavior by fans who are completely
out of [__] control and were back in
the day we probably even worse because
because there was no cameras dude I mean
it was [__] you know the [__] that
was said you didn't bring women or kids
to the game but like every once in a
while an athlete just like in hockey
Paul which started last night two nights
ago you gotta you know if every once in
a while like somebody just went in the
crowd beat the [__] out of somebody's
dad who got a little sideways I think
the behavior at the crowd and and then
stadiums would be a lot better yeah and
and um they just showed something with
saquan Barkley and sequan tweeted like
don't turn me into that [__] you know
what did but somebody was cheering
Daniel Jones's neck injury and sequin
heard him and sequin just turned around
and goes you're a little [__]
[__] you know that like and he
did it so kind of low-key and he was
right and it was just like yeah man like
you don't cheer a guy's neck injury you
don't cheer a guy to be hurt you don't
cheer a guy to be
hurt you know Paul when you throw your
back out and you can't golf I never
[Laughter]
cheer what's your record for the year
the silent assassin how you doing over
there um up and down these last two
weeks though I've been pretty pretty
good um what was it 4 and0 week four and
then week five that's pretty good it's
pretty good is that
good is good [__] play over there
yeah this week was like three and one
two and two um you know around there
because the Texans and Packers were kind
of tough losses but I picked the same
game three and one and two- two if I'm
doing my math correctly you're eight and
three over the last three weeks that's
pretty good jakay yeah yeah but you know
it's up and down you never know what
happen we signed you on this show you
had you had a contract that you weren't
gon to do better than the hosts all
right you're in violation right now all
right let's get back to it here Jake
killing it man killing it all right so
uh Andrew this is week six that means I
have the first pick yes uh bill it's all
about you
Paul just sitting here waiting for your
first pick hey hey it's my turn [__]
prom queen over here hey you know I
don't know what you want me to tell you
if it was your turn I would give you the
Baton the Baton uh
baton um dude this I'm not gonna lie I
was I was just saying before you came on
looking at these lines there's like six
games that are under three
points um but the first pick that I'm
just going to go with the game that that
that stuck with me from when I saw it I
saw it at the beginning and I'm going to
stick with it they're at home I'm going
to I like Joe burrow again I think that
they're gonna go turn turn the season to
500 because they're two and three right
now they're minus two and a half at home
against Seattle even the Giants hung
with Seattle until they made horrible
horrible mistakes late in the game I
think Joe Burrow's leg is better the way
he was launching that [__] thing last
week I I I like the bang Les minus two
and a half at home that's one I could
kind of sleep if they lose I could sleep
uh I'm GNA go I'm coming out of the gate
Paul I'm coming out of the gate I I like
the the the the the Philadelphia
Eagles um I just think they're way more
talented than the Jets and they got one
of the best offensive lines and Paul
who's kidding who there a lot of
quarterbacks getting a ton of [__] out
there and and if you really watch the
game all they're doing is running for
their life and they don't have time for
the play to set up Jimmy Garoppolo guy
was running for his [__] life Daniel
Jones Daniel Jones running for his life
M Jones running for his life oh bringing
bringing [__] zippy a zappy he's
running for his life Joe Burl oh
Jesus Jake you trying to give me a
little [__] little hint there with
that two and a half I like that uh so
I'm gonna take the
Eagles um also sort of my lowkey uh
upset to go to the Super Bowl I just
think everybody's like oh the 49ers you
really prove some with the Cowboys and
blah blah blah all the money's going to
go that way and what's Vegas going to do
Paul they're going to pick up a green
phone and
make make a phone call and that's plus
seven
Bill pry not ready for this NFC
Championship
game all right so I'm taking the Eagles
minus
seven Eagles minus 7even
huh all right well got quiet there I
Paul knew his first pick I don't think
he knew his second pick no I I I've been
looking um I
think listen I like I like dude you know
I think this is the first time I'm
picking them this year they're at home I
I really don't think what's going on in
Washington is good I think Ron Rivera is
they're talking about him being on the
hot seat they started out okay dude the
Falcons are quietly three and two and
they've been in every [__] game
pretty the Falcons are have been there
um they are minus two and a half it's a
game at home I'm gonna take this and I
heard a stat now this could be bad or
good but this kid Riddler rid Riddler
that what's his name the [__] uh you
know the kid he's never lost a home game
in college or or in the pros when he's
home he hasn't lost a home game this kid
as can I ask you a question Paul what in
the [__] does that have to do with this
week I I just those a completely
different team I just said that it has
nothing to do with it but it's
interesting that's all I said it's
interesting all right you know what it
is Paul I have a lot of pressure right
now my kids want me to go take a
miniature golfing I told them I had to
do a podcast so they're like you know in
their pajamas still acting like they're
ready to golf and they're giving me [__]
so I maybe I've been a little too wound
up I
apologize uh I'm gonna take the Falcons
minus two and a half at home you're out
of your [__] mind no I'm kidding at
against the hapless I shouldn't say
hapless yet but against the wavering I
don't know Washington commanders I got
the oh we're just seeing it the exact
opposite because I like the commanders
I'm not gonna pull the trigger yet but I
I just feel like the [__] Falcons are
the Falcons and every time you think the
Falcons aren't the Falcons they start
falcony I like the Ravens to bounce back
these are two teams I like the Ravens
and the Titans it's at the
Titans I don't know I feel like whatever
the Titans were doing is not working
anymore I don't know if they're they're
running back the used them too much or
something but they were like steady yeed
for me the Ravens lost for me last week
I'm staying with this stripper man I'm
not breaking up with it yet I'm gonna
take the Ravens minus four so I got
two that's a great pick that's in London
and the Ravens have been resting in
London so that's a great
pick we'll see we see what are the
Titans been doing what do they go to
Amsterdam and they're doing Titans are
[__] dude the Titans I'm done with
that the Titans stink so ra Ravens are
laying four right yep okay cool I'll
take the Ravens laying for that's a
great that's a win that's a dub I think
well then you would have taken it all
right dude no I didn't see it dude I uh
I mean what's going on with you man you
got like my my dog just died [__] Vib
no because no no no no no no I'm just
concentrating these lines are [__]
scaring me man like this is a week
everything's three two and a half I
don't you know what I mean I'm
concentrating you know listen bill
that's as good as not just listening
what are you doing Paul I'm
concentrating uh yeah man like this this
I'm not gonna touch that
game I just don't know I'm gonna you
know what
man oh this scares me I'm gonna this is
like when the dollars the I mean the
dollar collapsing and Paul B saying I
don't know I mean those are two thing I
mean I I never heard I never Paul I've
known you almost 20 years I never heard
you say I don't
know on Sports Paul you always
know dude is Sequon playing I see I
don't know if saquon's playing they're
not listing it yet the Giants are
getting oh they're disrespecting your
[__] Giants big by two touchdowns and
a half a
point they're gonna get up Paul and then
they're gonna go into the [__]
prevent and they're going to give you a
touchdown maybe a back door cover
happens who's your backup quarterback
Daniel Jones hurt his neck Tyrod
Taylor Tyrod Taylor Tyrod Taylor Tyrod
Taylor mobile Tyrod Taylor getting first
downs eating up the clock Tyler Tyrod
Taylor should have been the starting
quarterback of the [__] San Diego
Chargers but went to numb him up they
punctured his lung and that's how he
lost his job
Paulie all right here's what I'm going
to do dude I didn't want to do it I'm
gonna do it I'm calling on Audible right
now during the show here you go this is
liveaction
audible I'm gonna I'm GNA give this to
I'm pointing I'm pointing at the I'm
pointing at linebackers I got pencils
everywhere I got pencils I got [__]
uh I'm gonna go with the I'm gonna go
with a team whose quarterback has yet to
throw an interception this
year and they're in every game and I got
bit in the ass at the last second which
I would have went 4 and0 I'm going to
give him another shot this week at home
I'm going to take the Houston Texans
formerly known as the Houston Oilers at
home against the Saints getting one and
a
half all right Paul that they're the new
franchise the Titans were used to being
known as the Oilers then they became the
Tennessee Oilers I know sorry I didn't
mean to Fu I just got to make sure you
know these kids today they don't they
don't know the goddamn history all right
now it's supposed now it's it's it's
Billy Underdog time um I just think the
Bengals are going to be back and forth
all this year I don't think that they
got the pieces or whatever I do love Joe
burrow and that type of stuff but I just
think
um two and a half I [__] hate two and
a half but I don't know Seahawks man I I
just
think I think Gino Smith I think uh metf
I like their defense even though you
know they haven't had the greatest
defense but like that's what people said
last week when they go they don't have a
good defense well they [__] the under
still came in
uh and then Pete Carol I just think
Sneaky Pete is really good at coming up
with a game plan for the players that he
has uh to be hanging in two and a half
you [__]
[__] oh H all right I'm taking the
Seahawks I'm G taking the Seahawks two
and a
half another all right that's another
head-to
head another head to-head and I'm trying
really hard Paul
to not take the commanders too because I
don't believe in the [__]
Falcons the Falcons are that bipolar hot
chick you date you
know she says she loves you and then you
come outside and what has she done Paul
she she [__] knifed up your
convertible
top all right um I love your pick so far
this weekend I'm really not just saying
that I bill is steady Edy
dude uh me you're right I just come out
it's a slug fest with me the first half
of this
year there's no boxing these guys just
two guys beating the [__] out of each
other you in the bookie you guys are
like in a slap fight and neither one of
you has gone down
yet all right here's the deal
dude which I'm going with the team that
got so embarrassed I'm going with the
team whose fan base is disgusted I'm
going with the fan base that just can't
handle it anymore and they got [__]
[__] slapped just like my Giants week
one that's what happened to them last
week but this week they are two and a
half Point favorites on the road against
the Los Angeles Chargers I am gonna take
the Dallas Cowboys after getting spanked
by the 49ers to bounce back write the
ship I know they had a tough week at
practice after that beating and Dak is
they're calling for dak's head I think
he's going to bounce back and have a big
game I'm goingon to take the Cowboys
uh at Sofi minus two and a half you know
what's funny I stayed away from that
game and after listen you break down the
game I [__] love that
pick I love that pick because the
Chargers are another team who the [__]
are they yeah who are you all right can
somebody explain to me why the Vikings
are only two and a half Point favorites
over the Bears did half of their team
yeah Justin Jefferson Justin Jefferson
the number one receiver in football he's
out for at least six weeks uh Kurt
Cousins been running for his [__]
life there every it's it's a mess over
there when the [__] did it become a mess
over there um all right now now I'm
flying by the seat seat of my freckled
pants here I gotta I gotta pick a
[__] game
here Cardinals getting six and a half at
the Rams classic divisional rivalry
those games are usually close Lions
minus three the buck who are the
Buccaneers Paul Dolphins 13 and a half
over the Panthers I [__] hate all of
this Paul I hate all of this do i r on
four I mean dude the lock of the week
for me if if if Daniel Jones and sequan
played the 14 and a half is is a lock
for the you know but I don't know if
he's gonna come back his ankle taped up
it's why I couldn't pull the trigger
bill that's why that's why Paulie looks
confused this week I don't know because
they're not they're not announcing
they're not announcing the injuries if
they're gonna play it's like game time
decision [__] dude how the [__] did the
Saints win 34 to nothing and now they're
only minus one and a half
favorites the Texans defense is that
[__] good huh I mean they they've
been in every game huh the Texans are
coming man I really they're good like
might as well flip a coin I might as
well flip a [__] coin because I don't
like any of this
[__]
uh Patriots going to the Raiders I I I
don't even know who the Patriots are
anymore they're like the Sullivan
Stadium Patriots after [__] last week
still G to watch it though Paul still G
to watch it um all right for my fourth
and final pick he says while
stalling um I do that I'm gonna take the
commanders you know what the Falcons are
gonna [__] lose that game because
they're the Falcons oh bill and I got
two head-to-heads this week you know
what Paul if you win them both them
we're tied and that's good for the
ratings wait a minute what did I do here
no you beat once we went got 49ers I got
the Eagles I got the Seahawks and the
Ravens do I
feel went back on the 49ers you went
back on the 49ers you didn't take the
49ers you went to the Ravens yeah Ravens
commanders Seahawks Eagles well well oh
that's right because the 49ers went up
to seven and a half yeah from
six yeah [__] that game all
right hey
Paulie P I got my
picks you know what I'm looking at here
you know what I'm looking at here over
here Paul I'm looking at hopefully two
and two I'm scared week I'm
scared now your lips to your your words
to the to to from your lips to the
bookie ears however that expression goes
all right well now it's time
for oh let the Midnight Special
Bo some money for you come on we gotta
hit it this time let the Monday night
speci make some money [__] money for
you we've been you know what if people
have been sort of using our our our
Monday night special is like not the
parts car the part you have the parts
car and then the car you're building on
we keep going two out of three
Paul when the [__] are we gonna grow a
collective dick here and pick a [__]
winner for these people this week
Cowboys over the Chargers I like minus
two and a half I like that all right Dak
Prescott to throw one who's he gonna go
to to to Johnny lamb Jones CD
I
mean Tony pared healthy
Jake are you just picking him because he
has an Italian first name no what Paul
can't lay off a [__] Anthony a Tony a
[__] Kay tree whatever his [__]
name was in the Bronx tail what are we
doing here Paul put the pasta away and
let's use our [__] brains here that's
uh there's trivia for people Chaz pom's
real name name in real life is cadro and
that's why he did that in a bronx tail
that's what Chaz is short
for Chaz Jazz
yeah oh it's like cheer Cheerios I
thought he ate Cheerios while listening
to
Jazz
um you know some jokes hit some jokes
don't some pcks work some picks I'm the
two and two kid Paul even on the comedy
stage um I don't think we touch the
under over because it's just it's it's
what is it yeah it's 50 and a
half are you like the
under 50 and a half that's a lot of well
this is what I do think I think that
both both you know people think oh my
God the Chargers offense the Cowboys
offense and they I don't know I don't
know anything about the Chargers Paul
other than that they rent a football
stadium from the LA Rams how is their
defense the defense I mean dude dude
there H it's just one of those Mr
President how is your aching back
terrible their defense is
terrible oh is that what JFK said
terrible or
like slightly under average Jake's a
Chargers fan so he's coming honest on
this one I I don't think he's Happ the
defense they're underachieving how about
that they should be better all Jake you
like Dallas to win the you like Dallas
with the points or
no I mean no but I mean I'm gonna pick
my team
all right's he's in his feelings here I
like Dallas I think every okay so the
Chargers defense stinks I think
everybody's gonna think it's gonna go
over I think it goes
under there hasn't been a shootout in a
while Paul one of those [__] wow 34
to 28 games I I see it see I see a
shootout I see points in this I see a
shootout too I like it
Paul let's get a [__] eightball and
just watch this game dude I'm flying out
there no uh
what about what about passing over
unders right now it's Dak 257 and a half
uh Justin Herbert uh 281 and a half do
you think either one of those guys goes
over under I think Justin Herbert goes
over it's pretty good I agree I like
Justin Herbert to go over I like the
[__] over and I like the Cowboys to
win and I want to put some money in the
people's pocket Paul for once you said
that so confidently I'll go with that
you said that like that was GNA happen I
like it I just had a double espresso I'm
liking what my brain's saying right now
let's do it then let's do cowboys to win
by three Justin Herbert to throw 288
yards 281 and a half 281 and a half so
[__] that no no two so so wait a minute
so it goes to 282 so he just Gotta Throw
282 yeah all right so Cowboys to win by
three Herbert to throw flat 200 yards
Paul all he needs is one long one we're
in that Prescott over under to throw one
interception wait we're going we're
taking the under or the
over on the Herbert you guys said over
no no what's the third bet Cowboys to
win we're taking the over we think it's
gonna be a shootout Paul the over was a
third
Jake yeah 50 and a half 281 and a half
so we need a
okay oh so we need so we're just for
points on Monday night we're rooting for
points we're rooting for points
and we're rooting for the favorite which
makes no [__]
sense um all right I like it hey Paul we
both went to public schools here let's
not overthink this all right all right
we're in the parking lot we just cracked
open a first one and went down a little
hard now we're in the group all right so
I'm going to recap mine then Bill you
recap yours for week six I have the
Cincinnati bank Les minus 2 and a half I
have the Atlanta Falcons minus 2 and a
half I have the Houston Texans plus one
and a half and I have the Dallas Cowboys
minus two and a half paully favorites
this week all right I got the Ravens
minus foa against the Titans in
London uh I got the commanders and
Chiefs the Illuminati guys plus two and
a half over the [__] Falcons I got
the Seahawks plus two and a half over my
Ang Les I don't know why I'm doing that
I love Joe burrow uh I got the Eagles
minus
seven against those Jets Jets Jets Jets
coming off a victory on the road against
the Broncos you've seen it a million
times the fans are excited here we go
let's get it going again right into the
[__] drink Paul all right well those
are our picks and our Monday night
special will be the Dallas Cowboys minus
two and a a half Justin Herbert to throw
over
281 a half yards and the over 50 and a
half Monday night guys if you're rolling
with us let's get some points and
hopefully they pull it out in the end
sorry Jake The Snake what can you do
it's just one week uh it's just one week
your team happens to fall on Monday
night and we think Dallas is gonna
bounce back it's nothing personal Jake
the problem with the charges is they
don't have Jake on the sideline he's
that classic doesn't look like a
football guy but got these analytics I'm
telling you Jake is our Jonah Hill from
Moneyball you just lean over there's not
much expression you whisper in his ear
then he whispers back to you and then
you say what has to happen that's
exactly what it is and more times than
not the man is
Right Andrew Themis is the Brad
Pit oh that's guy that sells the movie
all right Paul Let's uh let's get out of
here I got to take my kids miniature go
to have funny Mini have fun mini golfing
with your kids that's it everybody just
go to the bed MGM app download the app
use bonus code Burr 200 B
rr2 put as little as $10 in you get up
to $200 in wages regardless of the
outcome of your first bet bet
responsibly the Survivor pool is still
there you can get into that still get
your prizes
and